hi everyone thanks so much for joining
me today I'm really excited to present a
brand new talk on everything you wanted
to know about making our packages but
we're afraid to ask
so I've split this talk into five parts
the first is motivations why would you
want to make a package so ask here how
many people in this audience have ever
made an our package okay it looks like
maybe around 40% 50% all right so we'll
start off with that why would you want
to become part of this group
next the making what are some of the
tools that can help you make our
packages we'll then move on to
documentation how do you write about
your package so that people can
understand the value of it how can you
improve your package so once you've got
your basic package working what are some
ways to make it even stronger and
finally how can you market your package
so why make a package or if you're some
of the people here who haven't made one
maybe one thing you're thinking is isn't
making packages for real programmers so
you know I'm just an art user and I and
I write scripts I do data analysis like
you know is this really for me isn't it
like really hard and really advanced and
I want to ask all of you a couple
questions so first you've got this we
can actually all make packages because
if you could answer yes to these
questions you can make a package can you
open and run our SAS our studio
sometimes can you install a package also
maybe sometimes
can you write our code can you write an
R function actually an addendum to that
can you learn to write an R function
even if you haven't ever before and if
you can do that yes you can absolutely
write a package another concern you
might have is well you know just making
a package take a lot of time and this is
a nice quote from Hilary Parker's great
blog posts on making an R package from
scratch where she said it took me such
little time that she wished she could go
back to and make the package the first
moment she saw it so she'd been thinking
of this is this big thing for her to do
and actually it was relatively
straightforward and was
really helpful in her future work now of
course every time you write a function
it doesn't necessarily mean you should
write a package so when is it time well
you might have heard this about writing
functions that if you've copied and
pasted code three times it's time to
write a function and the idea behind
this is that you know when you copying
pasting code it introduces the
possibility for error
it makes your code more verbose so it
might be time to write a function and
I'd say if you've used the same function
across three analyses it's a good time
to write a package and think about what
are things you do over and over again
that should be easy that are hard what
are the things that you think wow this
would have been really useful to have a
month ago so it's not a function or
something you've written that's really
specific to the analysis you're working
on right then but solves a generalizable
problem because there are a lot of
benefits to making a package even if you
just use it for yourself even if you
never share it with anyone it can save
yourself time and reduce the risk of
error but you might also share it within
your company or your team so a package
is a way of bundling your code together
and make it really easily shareable and
also putting that code together with
documentation so people understand how
they can use your function and finally
if you do decide to share your package
publicly it's a great way to give back
to the community because how many here
how many people here never use in our
package only use base are no one right
we all benefit you know whether it's a
tidy verse whether it's facial analysis
whether it's data dot table
we all have benefited from people in the
art community making packages and
sharing those publicly so how do you
make a package well there are two really
great tools that can help you dev tools
and use this many of you might be
familiar with dev tools even if you've
never made a package it's for example
how you can install a package from
github I and it's been around for a
while and it was developed to primarily
around making writing packages easier
but there's a really cool new package
called use this which among other things
take some parts of dev tools but also
add some new functionality around
writing pack
and I'll say it's basically completely
magic so how do you create a package
well you start by loading the useless
library and then you use the function
create underscore package you give it a
file path and the end of that file path
is your package name so I decided to
write a package for this talk called New
York our Kampf and then I'm gonna make
an our function in it that's called I
love New York our comp so what does this
function do well you have to answer true
or false and you know here if you give
the true answer you get one response if
you get false you get another one so if
you give true I mean how could you not
know I'll just make Jared and the whole
team very happy and if you answer false
it's very sad and I and I hope by the
end of these two days you will have you
know loved this conference as much as I
love it well now we have this basic
function let's add some documentation I
really recommend writing function
documentation early as soon as you
finish a function now in this case the
function I showed it was is relatively
simple right it was just maybe seven
eight lines of code there was only one
argument so even if you come back to it
in six months you could you could figure
out what it does you could read it again
but that's not going to be the case for
all your functions you might have a
function that goes a hundred lines of
code
maybe it has you know five or six
arguments so it's really helpful even
just for yourself to write down and
explain what the function is doing and
how because it's useful not just for
other people but for yourself so how do
you write function documentation you
start off by using this use this
function user oxygen MD and you only
need to use this once when making a
package this will set up the framework
and then what you do you go to your
friendly art studio and you go and you
insert oxygens skeleton so what this is
gonna do is insert the way for you to
write documentation and when I first saw
this I was a little bit intimidated
because I'd never seen this form of like
the comments and the apostrophes but
it's just a way that for our to take
what you write here and translate it
into documentation so I've written
things like the title the parameters the
arguments what those are what it returns
in an example so
how that translates is once that's
finished you can then document your
package you can have our process this
and then you can look it up just like
you would any other function
documentation another package and we can
see how what you've written here now
will translate to that so Title I wrote
will go into B the title in the
description the parameter value will go
under the argument section and we'll
also see the example so this is how we
write documentation for our functions
but how do you document your overall
package and why this is important is
function documentation is really helpful
when you know what you're looking for
right you know the name of the function
maybe you vaguely recomm I think I use
this function here I just don't remember
exactly how it works you do that
question mark but how do you get people
to understand you what's the purpose
your package well an our package comes
with a description file and so here's
one for the New York are calm so it is a
couple sections here some have been
filled out like the title and I filled
out the authors but there's a couple
empty sections so here we see that the
title right now is this filler title
that it starts it off with same with the
description so these are things that
you're going to want to fill out and
we'll see how they become important when
your package has them I find it helpful
to think of package documentation as a
pyramid so we start at the top with a
name of the package which is going to
evoke what the package does then we go
down and we get a little more of your
boast with a title which is one sentence
a description one paragraph a readme and
then finally a vignette and I want to
emphasize that I find package
documentation it's really important for
explaining the value of the package and
introducing the main function so telling
people why they should care about the
package and what problem it might help
them solve what's in a name in our case
when you create a package you do have to
name it so this is a choice I've already
made I've called it New York archons but
you know if I was writing a more serious
package there's a couple of things I'd
consider one is that it's not taken on
cran so even if right now the package is
just for yourself you want to leave the
option open that maybe someday you do
want to submit it and you won't be able
to if it's a package name that's already
been taken on cran it's not too long
don't want people typing in library this
is a really long function package name
and there's lots of room for typos right
that wouldn't be very nice to users not
very nice to yourself either it's easy
to Google so you know there are some
packages that have common names and some
really great ones I love like janitor
broom which I'll talk about a little
later but an advantage that other ones
like ggplot2 and deep hire have over
that is when you google it the first
things that pop up will be the package
because these are not you know common
household items or have other uses and
finally we have evokes what it does so
this is you know really important it's
great if someone can understand just
from hearing your package name get an
idea of what it does so again some
examples might be string are right okay
it seems like something that's probably
working with strings a package that can
help you with this is the available
package from our open sigh so what this
says is if you give it your potential
package name it'll check things like is
it available on crayon and on github it
will give you some things like is there
a sentiment associated with this here
are the Wikipedia pages and even urban
dictionary so you can check that there
aren't any unintended meanings behind
your package name always good especially
yeah you know you never know what people
come up with now there may be some other
more esoteric considerations so here's
Sam Tyner talking about the per package
and how she was explaining it to a
colleague that it's per you know PU RRR
there are 3 R's and Mar Averett comes in
at explaining why and it's because
Hadley wanted it to line up nicely with
tidy R and D PI R so that's why the per
package has 3 R's in it so you may let
other considerations come in besides the
one I showed now a title for your
package it describes what the package
does and it has to be one sentence and
ideally less than 65 characters so again
this goes in the description file I
showed you but if you share your package
on github it also goes on top of the
github page and in the Google preview
results so a couple good examples is
deep deep liar
it's a grammar of data manipulation
shiny easy interactive web applications
with our our CPP seamless RN C++
integration and what's really nice about
this is they
even though it's pretty short it tells
you what the package does but it also
gives you a bit of that value right it's
not just R and C++ integration it's
seamless integration it's easy
interactive web applications so these
are some really nice examples of how
even in a short amount of space your
title can be really helpful a
description is one paragraph that's
focused on the value of your package so
here's the Broom package i mentioned
earlier and i really like its
description because it does a couple
things it starts with a summary sentence
so this is about we see summarizes key
information about statistical objects
and tidy Tibbals it then goes into the
benefits why is this helpful
well it makes it easy to report results
or work with a large number of models at
once and in brooms case it has three
main functions and so it makes sense in
the description to describe those three
functions and talk about what it does a
readme is a is a nice little bit longer
form documentation but ideally not too
long and it's a great place to point
people where to start and where to go
next you know many people might only see
this and not read the longer form
documentation I talked about with the
vignette so to read me a good place to
start as an overview this is the for
cats readme which I helped contribute to
in the tidy verse developer day and it
starts out with what's the goal of for
cats well it's make working with factors
easier I show some of the functions that
the forecast package has and why you
might want to use them and I also point
people to where they can learn more next
I give some installation instructions
and this is helpful as well to know if
the packages on cran if you can use
install that packages and then give some
examples so in the readme case you don't
want to necessarily overwhelm people but
it's helpful to give you know one or two
examples of how a person might use this
so in this case I give an example of how
FCT underscore lump can take a factor
with lots of levels and put the ones
that aren't very frequent into one
factor level called other a vignette is
this longer form it's a case study it's
I advise to use real and interesting
data for this so don't make something
like a B and C and like very artificial
for how you would use your package it's
really nice to give people an example of
how could they use this in the real
world if it's
statistics package you can use it make a
model if it's a visualization package
make a graph so it really makes sense a
tailor to what the goal of your package
is so in this case with for cats because
for cats is working with factors some
functions they are helpful with graphs
so in this case I show how a for cats
function can help reorder your graph
into the ascending order
I also repeat a little bit of the readme
and show with FCT lump so it's okay here
to be repetitive it's okay to have some
shared things across your documentation
because again people might not see them
all well now we have a pretty good
package and it's nicely documented how
can you improve it and there of course
lots of ways but I want to concentrate
on one so who's had this before where
something's working it's going great
everything's fine and then right where
you need it it just completely falls out
from under you so how can you prevent
these cases solution here is unit test
so this is a nice quote from having
Wickham which says you may think I am
making these silly mistakes on purpose
for teaching purposes that is not true I
make these mistakes all the time and
it's the unit test that saves me so it
doesn't matter how good an our
programmer you are you will eventually
make some mistakes or when you're
refactoring your package something that
worked before will break and so unit
tests are how you can keep developing
safely how you can write tests you first
set up with use this use underscore test
that and just like use rock to Jen MD
this one you only have to do once and
this sets up the structure and then you
make a file use test for I Love New York
our conference so in this case I made
two tests I wanted to test that the
function defaults to true and that it
fails if it's given not a logical so
test that works you do things like
expect underscore equal in this case
expect underscore error I expect this to
throw an error I expect this to be true
I expect this to be greater than so you
write down your expectations and then
you can have it so that you check when
you're developing new functions you can
always be checking that it's passing
your tests so I really recommend to
write them early and often because that
way you can safely iterate knowing that
your core functionality is not affected
and whenever you fix a bug put in a test
would have caught that because again
that's an error you've already seen
happen and you know just because it's
happened once it absolutely can happen
again even if you fix it so right
something that would catch that and let
you know if it's reintroduced so a final
thing is how do you market your package
and I'd like to start by saying
marketing is not a bad word I think it
could have a negative connotation but
it's equally important even if it's
something just used within your company
or team because marketing will help
people know what they can get out of
your package and it helps them it's not
a selfish thing you've written this
because it's useful for you and that
makes it very likely that it's useful
for other people so the documentation
was a great start a vignette or readme
will all help explain the value but
there are a couple ways you can go
beyond that the first is to publish your
package on github if you're not familiar
with git or github it's beyond the scope
of this talk but I highly recommend
reading Jenny Brian's book happy git and
github for the use are because it walk
you through step by step how to get
started and this is a way that really
lets you easily share your package with
other people and also eventually maybe
have other people contribute to it too
because github allows folks to file
issues if something is not working for
them a pull request which says hey I've
written some code that maybe as an
additional test or fixes a bug and I
think can help develop your package so
it's a nice way to integrate to have the
community help with your package
development as well make a website with
package down so I actually just made one
for a package that I wrote just a few
days ago and I really liked how easy it
was so you use the package down function
build site you push it to github you
change one little setting and voila you
have a whole package and what this does
is package down takes the readme you've
written the vignette the details in your
descriptions we see the developers here
on the right and it takes all of that
what you've already written and just
repurposes that into a website so once
you've done that documentation it's
really easy to them make a website and
share that with more people you can blog
and tweet about it this is a night suite
from Jim Hester about his package room I
recommend if you do this use the are
stats hash tag it's a really great way
to have folks even if they don't follow
you to find out and discover
your package give the a one line
motivation what again what problem would
this help users saw solve why would they
care so in this case it's to read CSV
TSV and fix with files quickly you can
remit remix your readme and vignette in
this blog post so again there's a
there's a common you know idea of dry
don't repeat yourself in programming and
I actually say with documentation
repeating yourself is good again maybe
some people will find your blog some
people find the readme some people will
find the package down site some people
will see the vignette it's okay to have
one core message across all of these
things and to be reusing some stuff
again tailored for that format the final
thing is you can submit your package to
crayon and this could be a whole talk in
itself but I will just say with Hadleys
quote here that the majority of our
users do not install packages from
github so github is a great way to start
sharing a package but if you want it to
be really widely used it will have to go
to cran that being said I think it's
nice to wait to submit to cran until you
have a stable user facing API you don't
want to go ahead and submit if you're
going to be changing a ton of things
that will mean the functionality users
have come to depend on will change
finally if you're successful you can see
this is my brother dear off here about
his broom package how he felt when he
first got his first github pull request
I was really exciting the community was
engaging
Mickey's happy how he feels now when he
looks at the github issues for broom
fortunately broom has been taken over by
another maintainer maybe for this reason
so it is a really exciting thing you
know and eventually it can become you
know bigger than you ever imagined so I
like to end this talk which is a few
resources first can I get a bit of a
drumroll please
there is a new are packaged book in the
works so the first are packaged book
from Hadley Wickham a couple years ago
excellent resource but didn't have some
of the newer tools like use this
jenny/brian is now writing a new edition
with Hadley it's still in development
but you can find it at our - packages
org it's already excellent it's again
it's still in the works but has some
really great new material and from the
advanced are some other resources that
are really helpful I won't go through
them all but these are some great blog
posts and tutorials on different parts
of writing a
[ __ ] and with that thank you all so
much and look forward to speaking to you
for the rest of the conference
[Applause]